bonjour François Legault remet son
chapeau de Premier ministre pour
quelques heures
qui ont été ouverts il fait le point
avec la sécurité publique sur les dégâts
potentiels dans l'Est du Québec
juste à côté des îles donc
mais les équipes le rassurent il peut
retourner à sa campagne électorale on a
contacté les quatre autres chefs hier
soir on l'a leur expliquer la situation
pour continuer de le faire toute la
journée ce matin on voulait juste voir
la situation de ce qui se passe aux îles
quand on a constaté que tout allait bien
on est on a continué mais il faire plus
pense les autres chefs la totalité du
nombre de perturbations et d'événements
comme ceux-là c'est assez clair qu'il y
a un lien avec les changements
climatiques c'est ça dont on parle quand
on parle de la nécessité d'en faire un
enjeu du 21e siècle c'est aussi c'est un
rappel qu'on doit pas seulement lutter
pour freiner les changements climatiques
mais qu'on doit aussi investir de plus
en plus pour s'adapter le chiffre kaki
c'est un maintien que son plan de 7
milliards de dollars pour une économie
verte suffira alors que les
municipalités réclament 10 milliards
pour se doter d'infrastructures leur
permettant de répondre au changement
climatique d'ajouter 10 milliards
par-dessus ça
c'est non mais les programmes qui sont
existants je pense qu'il y a une bonne
partie que ça va être pour les
municipalités justement pour s'adapter
François Legault avait déjà prévu que sa
campagne ne mènerait aux Îles de la
Madeleine lundi il juge maintenant cette
visite nécessaire pour constater les
dégâts et apporter son soutien au
madelino